aujourd'hui le concept de concept pour
le cours de sciences sociales du collège
visitation à perlière le cours de
sciences sociales utilise un bon nombre
de concepts mais qu'est ce qu'un concept
un concept c'est une idée qui permettent
de regrouper de manière objective un
ensemble d'éléments différents quelqu'un
qui ne connaîtraient pas une table
serait bien étonné si je lui dis que
tous ces éléments en fait selon la même
chose c'est-à-dire répondent au même
concept
on est bien d'accord que outre mes
représentations mes apprentissages si je
regarde vraiment les choses telles
qu'elles sont cette table est très
différente de celle ci ou de celle ci en
fait elles sont toutes très différentes
les unes des autres que ce soit en
termes de couleurs de matières de formes
de tailles
dès lors comment peut-on définir un
concept qui plus est un concept en
sciences sociales un concept est une
construction abstraite exprimée par un
mot seul mot est une étiquette qui
désigne une liste d'attributs laquelle
est susceptible d'être appliquée à des
exemples cette définition comporte donc
trois éléments un code c'est à dire une
étiquette
si vous voulez c'est le mot le mot qui
va me permettre de regrouper toute une
série de choses différentes
autour d'une même catégorie évidemment
ce mot correspond à une définition et
cette définition comprend des attributs
dans le cas de la table les attributs
d'une table basse ce sont simplement des
pieds et un plateau qui vient se poser
sur c'est plié ça c'est vraiment les
deux attributs du concept de table
évidemment les exemples sont des cas
concrets qui montrent autant de tables
qui répondent au même concept
en classe des élèves parfois pose la
question mais qu'est la défense un
concept et une définition une définition
c'est une formule précise mais le
concept lui va plus loin parce qu'il
permet vraiment d'avoir des critères
très précis mais qui sont en même temps
applicables à la réalité parfois les
définitions sont très théoriques tandis
que le concept est quelque chose de très
pratique
finalement enfin le concept c'est la
relation réciproque entre les
caractéristiques et les cas concrets
par ailleurs la confrontation des
exemples et des contre exemples permet
la compréhension des concepts mais aussi
un réel débat d'idées entre les élèves
et dames
si je prends des exemples de concept
outre celui de table qui n'est pas un
concept de sciences sociales je vais
prendre un concept de sciences sociales
que nous allons utiliser celui de
famille la famille quels sont les
attributs d'une famille une famille
c'est plusieurs personnes en même temps
qu'ils ont un lien de parenté
alors le lien de parenté peut être lié
au sens vraiment le père la mère les
enfants ou une alliance
le mari et la femme ça peut être
éventuellement une nouvelle forme de
famille type les familles recomposées ou
les familles qui se sont construites
autour de l'adoption
évidemment on à la présence d'ascendant
de descendants ou de collatéraux commun
et puis la famille a une fonction de
liens ou des liens qui sont affectif
matériel ou économique
ces quatre attributs me permettent de
définir ce qu'est le concept de famille
évidemment j'ai beaucoup de familles
différentes
j'ai des familles plutôt qu'ils se
rapprochent du clan sur le plan en
concert se considère comme une famille
j'ai les familles monoparentales avec un
seul parent j'ai des familles
recomposées reproposer pardon j'ai les
familles royales les familles nucléaires
c'est à dire papa maman et les enfants
uniquement
donc j'ai beaucoup d'exemples différent
de famille en même temps j'ai des contre
exemples des couples est ce que le
couple et une famille pas vraiment
les pensionnaires de homes
une famille pas vraiment quand je parle
du ménage en tant que concept
socio-économique est ce que je me
rapproche du même type de famille pas
vraiment puisque en socio économie à
minaj ce sont simplement des gens qui
résident sous le même toit ce qui est
précisé ici c'est que certains contres
exemples peuvent comporter un des
attributs plusieurs attributs mais pas
tous c'est pour ça que ce sont les
contrées voir le dernier élément qui
faisait préciser ici c'est que certains
attribuent constituent des invariants
absolue d'autres sont plus relatif et
peuvent varier plus ou moins dans le
temps et dans l'espace
la famille il ya 150 ans avait certaines
caractéristiques communes certains
attributs communs avec la famille
actuelle mais d'autres ont bien changé
évidemment donc il est toujours
intéressant de confronter les concepts
dans le temps et dans l'espace d'aller
voir si le concept existait sous la même
forme avant ou ailleurs mais à quoi sert
un concept les concepts permettent tout
d'abord la mise à jour des connaissances
dans le contexte social contemporain en
fait un concept c'est une représentation
mais une représentation théorique et
objective
l'idée c'est de rompre de remplacer une
représentation du sens commun ou en tout
cas de les affiner
grâce à ces concepts qui sont plus
précis les concepts oblige les élèves a
comparé le discours abstraits avec la
réalité qui les entoure et ce pour ne
pas exclure les phénomènes qu'ils
désirent étudier
évidemment la construction d'un concept
permet de bien comprendre la réalité
parce que je me posais une question mais
tiens si je parle de deux pages du
concept de dopage qu'est ce qui est du
dopage est ce que le fait de s'injecter
comme les nageurs l'ont fait un
certainement de l'air dans les intestins
est-ce que c'est considéré comme du dup
dopage donc le fait d'utiliser un
concept permet aussi de rationaliser et
de mieux comprendre la réalité
en ce sens ils permettent de structurer
la réalité grâce à lady aux différents
attributs
qui permettent vraiment de construire
des catégories enfin il détermine un
cadre de référence dans la communication
entre élèves entre chercheurs de
sciences sociales entre professeurs on
peut utiliser le même concept parce
qu'ils ont le même sens c'est un peu la
différence entre concepts aussi et la
définition la définition elle peut
changer tandis que le concept il est une
fois défini une fois pour toutes
et ça ne change plus donc on sait
exactement quand on parle d'exclusion
sociale par exemple de quoi il s'agit
vous avez ici une série de concepts qui
sont préconisées par le programme du
cours de sciences sociales il ya
différentes catégories les concepts
psychosociaux qui sont plus généreux et
puis les concepts culturelle des
concepts socio-économique et des
concepts institutionnels et socio
politique
la reproduction la socialisation la
société le travail le marché la
globalisation les tic les médias le
système politique sont autant de
concepts qu'on pour aborder bien sur
cette liste n'est pas exhaustive
ce qu'on demande souvent aux élèves de
sciences sociales ses de conceptualiser
c'est à partir d'une réalité qui
comporte un certain nombre de
différences c'est finalement de
construire un concept qui permet d'aller
chercher les ressemblances
on disait les invariants ceux qui ne
varie pas entre les éléments observés
je vais ici vous donner un exemple marc
apprécie les belles voitures
il en possède plus d'une dizaine
fabienne a des difficultés pour bloquer
bloquer ses fins mois pour boucler
pardon ses fins de mois
elle doit se serrer la ceinture jusqu'à
ce que les allocations soit versé sur
son compte
farid occupe une fonction de cadre qui
lui permet de vivre confortablement
en fait le concept qui est derrière tout
ça mais c'est le concept de niveau de
vie de richesses mais un niveau de vie
est un concept plus adéquat l'on voyait
j'ai des situations bien différentes sur
lesquels je pourrais avoir des avis de
bien différent mais derrière tout ça il
ya quelque chose de commun hier ce
concept vraiment
de niveau de vie on pourrait faire un
exercice avec des images ou des
photographies voilà quel concept selon
vous se cache derrière ces différentes
photographies faites pause si vous
n'avez pas d'idée quand vous avez un peu
déchiffrer ces images et vous avez une
idée de concept fait plaît et je vous
donne à la pause
voilà la réponse il pourrait y en avoir
plusieurs ça peut répondre au concept
d'élections ou éventuellement mais je
trouve que c'est moins adéquat au
concept de démocratie ou deux hommes
politiques est évidemment politique
pourrait également convenir comme
concept par rapport à ces différents
éléments deuxième petit exercice
vous avez trois documents une
photographie un dessin en tout cas une
représentation graphique et une petite
citation qui est yved une des
interrogations que nous avons fait en
début d'année ensemble les personnes
souffrant d'un handicap mental prenaient
leur repas séparément leur linge était
lavé séparément on éloigné d'eux les
jeunes enfants et si d'aventuré une
fille du village noué une relation avec
l'un d'eux elle était aussitôt désavoué
la réponse la voici
il s'agit du concept d'exclusion sociale
voilà cette vidéo est terminée je vous
propose des exercices sur le groupe
facebook du court vous pourrez vous
exercer ainsi à la conceptualisations si
vous avez bien sûr des questions
n'hésitez pas je suis à votre
disposition vous êtes un bon travail une
bonne tête journée et je vous dis à
bientôt